[Music]
St graa of the Blessed sailboat best
known for skipping school to complain
about the weather has a new object of ir
of your a the Jews specifically gr was
complaining about the state of Israel
and demanding that climate activists
stand in solidarity with the
Palestinians when a fellow climate
activist bewildered got on stage and
tried to get her to focus we have not
been listening the people in power have
not been listening I for a climate
demonstration not a political
[Applause]
fate
unocc no climate Justice unoccupied land
no climate Justice unoccupied
land no climate Justice on occupied land
what could that possibly mean